yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing swindles from canada let's see
new opponent okay when you get the same
opening like the game before now
classical Queens gambit this time with
Bishop to yourself yeah here like bt7
Esther new main line but c5 is regaining
some popularity recently and I haven't
looked at this for a very long time so
this is probably not the best not a bad
bad bet against me is it because I think
I've forgotten most of most of the serum
okay I think now d 494 is good for wide
so that doesn't work and my next move
Zuk z1 taking with the e porn here's a
little bit unusual black usually takes
with the night with nice traded the
likelihood for aluminum blackest easier
it's easier like then let's try like
that to play em deform okay we should
buy 795 as the thing if I can trade this
like takes Bishop takes time in great
shape get to control over deform
yeah here I mean the bishop oh nice this
is this queenside structure doesn't
really inspire that much confidence with
the bishop here and 126 that looks a bit
weak ish see I don't know how he covers
this in the first place Bishop d7 a 6 is
even hanging even though maybe he has
Bishop e3 something yeah so if i take a
6 just Bishop e3 sob it as it looks with
it but i can do can I boy what what
about playing up position will be here
okay 95 you can take the 94 how to do
this
before before there is a five like that
that's no good
I'll just bishop f3m or this one I
cannot decide and many moves looked good
bishop is six ok yeah i was thinking i
just take which is a slightly simplistic
solution I don't have to it is not even
at the immediate flag is simplistic and
is also probably not not helpful say I
want to go 95 paternity now I was it was
Miss Clayton i miss played that this is
just don't not enough
even has some D for ideas some cases
and he's 2 p-8 is impossible but that
I'm not happy alert was it should have
gotten at least a little bit out of this
and he I have absolutely zilch look at
it too and I need the bishop on the
forum maybe I can get this working
Bishop here d 6054 that could even be a
little bit he might try for some counter
play on the Kings side I will be 66 @
something quite serious actually after
being on the look out there that that
can be dangerous for my king
the bishop is quite clearly good a good
player on the four of it that's not
really doing that much on its own yeah
so look g6 probably justice mercy to
look is covering g2
[Music]
wait for it would be to play some o be
three and take a trade against be pond
and open March the airport but that
takes quite a while trying to bring the
Queen to c5 the Queen trade would help
that's a good one
ma and then Bishop h3 em that's that's
bad i missed this precise move autumn
I'm not sure that this is actually a
problem I might have something on the G
file
[Music]
isn't it I mean isn't that more
dangerous for him and it is for me time
worrying I'd really looks like it all of
a sudden
black resently saw a strange on a sudden
I was on the gphone there was just
nothing I had nothing somehow the
opening here should be a little
something I mean that line has a
somewhat shady reputation queen bee
three uh-huh directly going against the
pond okay I'm kind of curious about that
shouldn't this be a slide some things
but it doesn't seem to be in this this
okay the engine wants to keep the
tension with the move like Age 3 or be
three yeah that's actually two money
there is no real needs to take it was
probably some others are too simplistic
I mean does this must be roughly equal
now you're getting this counter play you
can defend all this big bones there a 46
should be required now I miss this okay
the capture is correct that I didn't
expect yes I mean really okay okay
and what I'm surprised about is that the
engine shows an advantage for black I
mean I can definitely believe a petrol
or so but I really wonder how you can be
worth maybe see 50 k 6 business this and
then you have this this okay six that's
very scary well I probably would have
lost that it might might be objectively
bad but I would definitely would have
lost that and yet it seems to be holding
him Queen h3 is much more logical i mean
this is this was ultimately getting into
trouble but even this isn't that bad we
should be aged out of coverage e6 only
here we have a it's really bad when t
didn't he doesn't need to resign but it
was probably pretty frustrating because
I mean it was clear that his position
was okay and even better at one point
until then you spoiled it into that
pretty pretty restraining ok guys thanks
for watching